hey what's going on it's Phil Byrne it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday July 30th 2018 what's going on
how I'm a little bit late here with this
podcast you know I was out there in
Houston Texas for two nights and Dallas
for one and I want to thank everybody
that came out and the weather was great
it wasn't that hot you know I mean was
hot but it wasn't like Texas hot when we
flew into Houston I saw you know nice
green [ __ ] grass and that [ __ ] I
didn't realize Houston was right on the
water I always thought you still had to
drive like an hour before you get to the
Gulf of Mexico I don't think I ever
looked at them I know a lot he goes a
little booze buggy you what's your
hurricane like you know I didn't I
didn't want to watch a bunch of people
losing their houses did you watch it
with your [ __ ] popcorn before there
was that disaster did you know that it's
at right on the Gulf unless you live
there that's actually you know something
every time I go to a state I kind of
look where everything's positioned and
it's so [ __ ] how like your brain
remembers it now I always thought Austin
was in between Houston and San Antonio
turns out it isn't it's not just
northeast of San Antonio on the
thirty-five and then like you know
[ __ ] San Antonio Houston no kind of
parallel with one another and of course
Dallas is all the way up there on top
Dallas Texas where the heat is real in
the titties ain't I had an awesome time
when I was up there and guess what guess
what old freckles has done he hasn't
drank this whole month oh did he want
one last night but he didn't I'm gonna
yes my new thing I'm drinking the way I
smoke cigars
once every 10 to 14 days if I do that if
I do that alone
I will cut down my drinking by at least
one hundred and seventy two percent no I
don't know what I would do
that's the game plan so I got a little
little little shindig August 7th then I
go right back on the wagon until [ __ ]
I'm gonna try to go back on the wagon
that's the hardest thing for me once I
go off a whole daddy's playing the game
again oh he's in the game he got a
little dirty
yeah so Nate Craig was out there with me
crushing it every single night and I
don't know don't have anything better to
say but I think it was weird was weird
going to Dallas not sending Vinnie a
text other than that it was a good time
all right they just bummed me out why
would I bum you up good news hey you
know something
his taste is something that you you
might not have known about me but sensed
when you were in my presence is I swear
to God if I wasn't a comedian I could
have been a manager well at least I
could I could have been a talent scout
you know telling you how many more do I
have to call number a long time ago I
said you know I'm watching this drummer
on Instagram at the pocket Queen
well that drummers gonna be sitting in
with the Seth Meyers show all this week
what did I say
go ahead go back and look at the old
podcast listen to him was right there I
could have done it I could have brought
the Red Sox out of their [ __ ] 86-year
curse earlier if they had me as a talent
scout I could just see enough I can't
see it sports I can't see every whatever
you know you know what it really is is
you make a fuss [ __ ] thousand guesses
and then one of them comes in and then
what you really do is you just brag
about it which is which is what I'm
doing
so anyways I'm back out here in Los
Angeles all right I'm sitting in a very
progressive manner you know when I
watched last night I watched a couple
episodes of Seinfeld's new comedians in
cars you got to see the Brian Regan one
the Dave Chappelle one is awesome it's
Dave Chappelle but this Seinfeld one the
car that Brian Regan likes I actually
liked it too but it's a
two thousand five like two-seater
Cadillac or something like that the
level would lie on all the episodes I've
never seen Seinfeld [ __ ] on a car like
he shed on that car from the way it
looked to the options to describing the
person that was going to drive it and
then Regan of course was Regan and he
was [ __ ] hilarious
I was kind of hoping he was gonna bring
up how much he did not care for Brian's
taste in cars but you should check it
out if you get a chance so anyways
here's my story so I'm in Houston right
and I'm supposed to fly up to Dallas and
once again I [ __ ] up I wanted to fly
into Love Field because that's the
smaller one in Dallas T and whatever
that [ __ ] Metro Airport whatever the
hell it is it's gigantic but this time I
actually went through Dallas Airport and
it it was it was really easy oh I know
why cuz I wasn't connecting connecting
through Dallas you always got to get on
that [ __ ] monorail and I swear to God
if you're if you're in Terminal B your
connecting flight is in terminal e and
you always have to go all the way around
you always miss it just by one sure you
could grab your bags and start running
through the airport
you know like OJ Simpson back in the day
I guess you know maybe that's an option
I don't know so anyways I was going to
fly up from Houston but Nate didn't get
a ticket thought we were driving up so I
was like at [ __ ] you know what I
can't remember last time I took the 45
north up to from Houston to Dallas and
cancelled my fight flight we just
[ __ ] drove up there and I got to tell
you man that is a that's an intense
State Dallas not Dallas Texas I mean I
mean there's just like nothing out there
and then all of a sudden you just you
finally [ __ ] come on something you
get so [ __ ] excited some sort of
barbecue joy like my god we should stop
there man near the middle of nowhere
everything starts looking good look at
it I got fireworks let's pull over man
gotta get some of those
I haven't seen anything any sign of
civilization for the last [ __ ] hour
but we ended up stopping this gas
station with a they got this checklist
of a key in a Slovakian
I don't want to start any [ __ ] wars
over their little dessert thing that
they have that some people put meat in
some people put fruit in it or whatever
and I only see him in Texas it's usually
when I'm on the 35 writing around Waco
Texas I was joking about that guy all
weekend you know Joel Osteen I was
teasing those people down in Houston
going like I can't believe you guys were
surprised that that guy didn't let you
into his house when the hurricane cave
you know he's selling out a basketball
arena talking about Jesus do you think
this guy's even remotely honest on any
level let's do that I have my eyes
closed going Jesus doesn't want you to
step on my blue rug I'm talking about
Dave Koresh anyways cuz that was named
David Koresh really good-looking guy man
you remind me that guy that whoohoo
started California Californication
he's also R in the x-files David
Duchovny sort of a David Duchovny sort
of understated by with them with like
Richard Gere's hair or was that I got
more of a Rambo haircut you know I got
to look it up now like if you could go
back in time we go to the cops right
before that guy went nuts hey man you
got to get this guy he's saying he's
Jesus Oh what's he look like uh you know
he kind of looks like a Rambo haircut
like David Duchovny with just a splash
of Richard Gere sounds like a cover of
People magazine from [ __ ] 1989 when
when I'm looking up David Koresh the
k-factor
he definitely would have got the plane
ticket to Vegas look at the guy you know
what I mean if you take off those
[ __ ] glass he looks like he could
have done the Bjorn Borg story here's
what's gonna freak me out how long did
this guy live from nineteen
59 in 1923 oh Jesus
it was C was 30
all he's 33 you know those Jesus freaks
that's when they like to die that's when
they like to die
Oh Jesus died at 33 so if I [ __ ] die
too
then that means I'm just as his father
or two made no sense
I thought I was gonna come out on son
anyways so I've been eating perfectly
the whole weekend and then I stopped and
I got a couple of those was I don't know
what the [ __ ] they called checklist of
I'll hang us I wanna get to the name of
them I can't find it was called like a
collage or something like that I can't
find it what the come on there it is
Kol ACH e oh my god that does it they're
delicious
hey Nia wait who's that oh you got your
book you want me to read your story baby
oh is it hi buddy hi buddy
I get kiss Wow all right oh the boss
baby do you guys like to listen old
freckles regio kids book oh you did okay
don't touch that don't touch that please
shade show me that was here yeah I have
to do a podcast man I don't know if I
could do this right now
all right from the moment the baby
arrived it was obvious that he was the
boss yeah he looks like it
he put mom and dad on the
round-the-clock schedule with no time
off thank you does this seem familiar
kiddo
Vaman with her right now and then he set
up his office right smack dab in the
middle of the house she's not even
listening to me I have like no charisma
here whatsoever she's finding the crap
on my couch way more interesting
he made demands many many demands you
got a little Trump suit on and he was
quite particular no I like that
if things weren't done to his
satisfaction he had a fit well sounds
like these parents need to pooch kick
him into his crib he conducted meetings
lots and lots and lots of meetings
hey I are you interested in this at all
I have to get back to my podcast keep
reading
alright many of the meetings happen in
the middle of the night
the funky thing when was this written
Marla Frazee is that an old black woman
Marla the funky thing look that came out
of nowhere
is it the 70s he never ever said a
single word that made any sense but that
didn't stop she wants to run around do
you want to look at this I just feel
like everybody's fast-forwarding through
this oh whoa
all right and then daddy went back to
his podcast the end that cool bye okay
Nia I have to get back to a particularly
excruciating the unfunny podcast that
I've been recording any time I start and
I start like promoting something or
whatever the hell I just did I die my
whole brain just goes out the damn
window you want me read that book again
okay sorry guys this is just part of it
not the boss baby bye Marla phrase from
the moment the baby or all right let me
get back to this so bye bye bye say I
love you
there you go she can't say she just goes
Niang Niang ya Shi yesterday after I
flew back from Dallas I landed at LAX
and I met a friend of mine believe it or
not who owns one of those vietnam-era of
[ __ ] helicopters the Huey u H ones
and he was there with his instructor and
they picked me up in the thing I Lily
Lily sounded like I was in [ __ ]
Apocalypse Now and you know we flew
around up the coast of Malibu and all
that stuff and then we landed at the
small airport got some lunch and then
they let me fly it and it was amazing
you know it's funny people always said
if you can fly in r22 you can fly
anything they are 22s the little egg
beater that I fly and it's kind of like
driving a car I would say with like no
power steering or power brakes you're
really doing it but despite all that
anytime you get a new helicopter it's
like it's not just like don't feel just
like if someone was to like taxi it out
for you and you just took off it's very
easy to fly anything but it's like when
you come to a hover you know and you're
doing little turns and stuff and trying
to set it down on the pad I don't know I
don't know that's when I sit there
thinking like that you know okay you
might be able to fly it but I don't
think he can maneuver it well so we just
didn't some pad work and then I flew
from Camarillo all the way out to to
Burbank
it was amazing it's [ __ ] amazing and
I want to thank my buddy to let me do it
not naming any names or any of that crap
now speaking out helicopters everybody
keeps telling me I got to see that new
for Tom Cruise Mission Impossible
doesn't it seem like my podcast lately
that I'm subtly throwing in advertising
I swear to god I'm not I watched that
movie the the death of Stalin yesterday
on the plane Jesus Christ I don't know
who the hell wrote that man how do you
turn that guy into a commie but somehow
they did it with theirs [ __ ]
hilarious
two of my favorites of all time steve
buscemi and jeffrey tambor I ran it
they're absolutely hilarious and I wish
I knew the name of the one of the other
League cronies they're [ __ ] amazing
movie this this [ __ ] you know what it is
I don't have my [ __ ] headphones I
don't have a microphone I just this is
like it's like kryptonite
you know I'm under the [ __ ] gun
I got to go [ __ ] meet somebody I got
I got no time we'll bill maybe if you
want driving flying around a [ __ ]
amazing helicopters you a-hole and
recorded this yesterday we wouldn't have
listened this mediocre shitty hey this
week I'm gonna be at rough and rowdy
rough and rowdy brawl August 5th this
podcast is nothing but promotion and
[ __ ] what the hell am I gonna be in
Youngstown Ohio you can pre-order the
fight at rough-in rowdy brawl calm rough
the letter n rowdy brawl calm they got a
pride verse prejudice they have gay Pat
is gonna be fighting this ex-felon who
doesn't like gays that's the that's the
title fight and then we have a cop
fighting a skateboarder you know and
then there's also a bunch of a bunch of
Cleveland Brown fans and Steeler fans
that want to beat the [ __ ] out of each
other and it's all done in the name of
fun I think that's it and watch that man
it's it's like a tough man competition
but with stories you know and its really
never-ending the kind of people that you
could the matchups with how much people
don't get along you know you could have
neighbor versus neighbor you get in the
gay community you could go with ex
boyfriends and girlfriends you know cuz
then it's still check on check guy on
guy right
[Laughter]
bearded ladies I don't know it's it's
endless and I can't wait to go but right
before I do that or the day after some
[ __ ] I'm gonna be in Rochester New York
home of Steve Gadd with with Dean Del
Ray
coming off a marvelous performance up at
the Just for Laughs festival
anyways I can't you know something
that's the first time ever I'm actually
starting to feel my goddamn age you know
and I was in Dallas the fact that I had
like two shows and I wrote up sitting
down in that friggin car I'm telling you
you know I I was like come on like it
seemed like I was had to go shovel
somebody's driving once I get out on the
stage I'm fine but actually I'll
probably find the whole time but I'm
just like just the thought of it two
shows never bugged me three was always
like all right what the [ __ ] what am i
working in a mine here I thought it got
into show business to have a nice easy
[ __ ] life here yeah this has been
like feeling my age so I got to get back
to I don't know what you know cuz I
shouldn't be feeling I just feel a
little bit my [ __ ] now so I'm like my
shoulders fine and now my knee is [ __ ]
up I don't know what the hell I did to
it
just crawling around playing with my
daughter all of a sudden just my knee
all of a sudden felt like really I don't
know what hot stinging pain but it's not
constant and it's only when I put
pressure on it so I don't think that
it's bone to bone thank God I think I've
been active enough to have that [ __ ]
this is one of my favorite things to do
by the way is to let you guys know what
some of my ailments are and then you
guys all just turn into doctors it's one
of my favorite things dude you know what
that is it's actually your kidney
hear me out one time there was this guy
right and it just [ __ ] goes into that
[ __ ] and he was out on the golf course
you guys you know I'm at the doctor look
at my knees and the next day he died of
a kidney apparatus
a kidney a order what did they call it
kidney hemorrhage hemorrhage certainly
was a that [ __ ] little checklist
Avakian dish and then then I went right
back to salads and I was fine and fine
fine and then late at night these
goddamn hotels they always get me they
always had the little snack thing I had
eaten perfect perfect perfect when I was
in Houston
unbelievably there was no snacks right
now everybody knows Houston was voted
unprecedent back to back they went back
to back is the fattest city in America
okay and this is no you know smelly this
is some little [ __ ] you know you're
not going up against cupcakes here in
America no pun intended
all right we're you some of the fattest
people on the planet I don't think we
are I gotta be honest with you maybe we
are but collectively but when you're in
the city you know you don't see a lot of
fat people there in the city there's
just too many eyes on you you know you
get out in the country man I mean [ __ ]
you can just walk your property [ __ ]
butt ass naked because if you know
nobody cares how fat you get and those
overalls what will hide the the first 40
pounds who's kinto remember Uncle Jesse
that big guy damn beer belly he had but
he had in the overall so he looked like
Santa Claus just a good old boy never
meanin no home his stomachs pulled the
booze and [ __ ] regret he doesn't even
know his kids was that what that whole
thing was about
he was Uncle Jesse and Bo and Luke were
cousins he must have come from a big
family because that should have been
odds out we should have been one of
their dads right cooter
she's crazy cootie got you eat your own
I'm actually at the end of the sixth
season of 77 Sunset Strip it got
canceled up to 20 episodes and I'm
really gonna miss that show and I hope
that me TV so I'm gonna look up right
now is gonna go back to Episode one
again because I missed it they start I
could have watched the whole series
since last November and I didn't even
know
was on and I would love to I really
wanted to see those first five episodes
because he was in LA anytime they were
in LA I would always hit pause just to
see if I could recognize where they were
there he goes me TV 77 Sunset Strip come
on man give me a [ __ ] showing give me
is showing schedules that went to 77 has
its roots in an underrated I don't care
about that
come on schedule watch it's gonna be
over I'm sorry we have no list things
are there weeknights at 4:00 a.m.
are they gonna start over again but you
stopped I didn't get one on Thursday or
Friday there's the a variety so let me
read some of the advertising hips we I
got nothing for you here this week guys
the Red Sox beat the twins there's
something we got the Phillies tonight
for some more exciting interleague play
they have interleague play like every
[ __ ] two days now you know they
always got any always got to kill it the
Yankees did [ __ ] big man they're
errant judge way guy [ __ ] chipped a
bone in his hand you know it hit him
right in the palm to Matt's got a
[ __ ] kill you know you know sometimes
like chip in your elbow seems like well
it's kind of sticking out so it wouldn't
hurt that much it's designed for that
but you know the inside of your palm but
chipped that as far as like the worst
bones to break here's another one cheek
bone yep meeting filed out on to [ __ ]
that uh obviously don't to break your
neck you break a toe you know what I
mean but do you think that they were
torturing you and they wanted you to
give up where the base was you could
handle a broken toe right you just do
that ah I was so bad I'm still not
telling you [ __ ] yeah you know once they
once the guy goes to the rusty tools
though it's it's like I meant what are
we doing here what the [ __ ] do you want
to know I don't give a [ __ ] what are
they gonna call me will you let me go if
I tell you I know you gotta kill me let
me just tell you where
everything is and you just take out the
drilling hey smiley
oh the itsy-bitsy spider went up the
waterspout are you doing you want me to
read the boss baby again oh you're
excited huh
whoa Oh bye see you later
alright let's show off here okay
laughing crying angry
surprised there you go
good job buddy
where's your toe toe you know that word
honey I have to read advertising here so
I can keep buying you food huh keep
buying any food yeah that's how it works
all right oh look at this first one
honey
whoa yeah oh it's okay buddy I'll be out
there in a minute I'll be out there in a
minute oh my god oh she's holding our
arms out Oh just holding her arms out
looking at me oh boy oh boy okay and now
I have to continue podcasting under
these circumstances alright first read
of the week honey
millions of people are using honey to
save money while shopping online and why
wouldn't they
it's very hostile it's free it's free
takes just two clicks to add to your
browser and save you ton and saves you
tons of money it's ingenious but one of
my absolute favorite things about honey
is how much better it makes shopping on
Amazon please personalize personalize
this to make it your own
honey Matt okay honey magically adds all
sorts of useful information on the
Amazon page of whatever you're looking
at
I am I supposed to make this personal
just shop like I normally do
honey hi oh honey automatically searches
the two million sellers on Amazon to
find you the lowest price yet even shows
you the items prices changes so you can
decide if you want to buy or wait for
the price to come up and down there
either right it even shows you the items
prices prices changes its price changes
honey
read it right if you do decide to wait
just add it to honey's drop list and
it'll notify you if the price drops when
honey's got you back you'll never
overpay for anything on Amazon again
there's no reason to not to add honey to
your browser today it's free and takes
just two clicks to install and we'll
make sure you always get to the lowest
price on Amazon add honey to your
browser for free right now at join honey
calm / burger that's joined honey calm /
/ in no G don't talk about how every man
looks better in his suit listen nobody
checks out the fellas like me okay I put
on my glasses I sit on a street corner
and I just wait for them to sashay past
and I got to admit I find time and time
again I'm just attracted to a man in a
suit it's confidence its success it says
I'm going places take my wrist honey
Indo Chino is the world's largest why
would you take his wrist you take his
arm right is the world's largest
made-to-measure menswear company and has
been featured in major publications
including GQ Forbes ah and Fast Company
she keeping a fast company they make
suits and shirts made to your exact
measurements / great fit guys love the
wide the wide select them at the wide
pants you know fat clientele guys love
the wide selection of high quality
fabrics and the option to personalize
all the details including your lapel
lining and monogram you got to have a
little health you know
when you're wearing a suit you
absolutely have to have a lapel just in
case you disappoint somebody and they
need something to grab here's how it
works first a showroom or shop or shop
online at endo Chino comm pick up your
fabric choose your customization to
submit your measurements wait for your
custom suit to arrive in just two weeks
this week my listeners can get any
premium Indo Chino suit for just $379
and Indochina comm IND o CH Ino all
capitals calm when entering BER at
checkout that's 50% off the regular
price for made-to-measure premium for
made-to-measure premium suit imagine if
I did this on vinyl and just got stuck
mate Imagi made Imagi plus shipping is
free
that's Indo Chino com promo code bar for
any premium suit but for just $379
including free shipping including
incredible deal for a suit that will fit
you better than anything off the rack
ever could alright hotel tonight honey
we have to [ __ ] now thank god there's
hotel tonight hotel tonight is the go-to
app for booking great deals at great
hotels
unlike other hotel booking sites hotel
tonight doesn't have long endless lists
of a zillion hotel choices instead hotel
tonight tonight tonight Oh what will
shows you the best deals at best hotels
they partner with top-rated hotels to
help them fill their unsold rooms which
is how you get such great deals and even
though the name is hotel tonight it's
not just for tonight
you can book tonight tomorrow or beyond
it's perfect for planners as well as for
crass donators when you give me a town
honey I can't plant another future you
can book spontaneous weekend's three-day
three-day you get it a [ __ ] threesome
getaway staycation road trips business
trips you can dress up like a nurse you
can book a hotel you just so you can use
the pool etc download the hotel tonight
app today to get great deals at Haute
you actually want to stay at and with
promo code bar you can get $25 off your
first eligible booking hotel tonight
promo code BRR
how many more of these I got to read all
right three down three to go we'll do
one more and then I'll give you a break
all right what are we good lar oh no
they're not selling asses owning a couch
from hell is like a rite of passage I
eat too expensive too heavy too cheap to
warn you found it on a street corner and
God knows who [ __ ] on it please use
one of your negative couch experiences
to contrast how amazing your new borough
conscious oh I used to live with Robert
Kelly back in the day and I think Bobby
watched Sanford and Son too much because
he was constantly bringing things in
from the sidewalk one of these was a
couch that he then put a bedspread over
which was I guess supposed to block out
the potential body lice or maybe broken
crack pipe that you could sit on you
know you know what you know what I
really wish other than that I could hug
Bob right now and tell him that it was
okay that he took that couch off the
sidewalk I really wish that burrow
existed back then cuz me and Bobby could
have [ __ ] ordered a couch right after
all these years of stuff was that
personal enough after all these years of
suffering you owe it to yourself to
experience the comfort and quality of a
borough couch boro boro brings style and
comfort to a whole new level and ships
to your door fast and P your
relationship with your couch will never
be the same I'm just not you
Burrow sofas are Aragorn amelie designed
so uncomfortable while I what do you do
most unburrow
not off while watching me TV cuz I think
you know it's most comfortable while I
nod off to TV customize your burrow sofa
to match your style by selecting the
color size armrests height and leg color
armrests hug wow that's brilliant
shipping is fast and free unlike the
rest of the future industry and did I
mention it has a built-in USB charger
wow man mister sounded like you could
take this
the space enjoy 30 days of cozy on your
comfortable burrow risk-free or try it
out in Perl at one of their partners
showrooms today and then what you can
bring it back roast
customize it doesn't say that oh you can
try it for free for 30 days customize
your own burrow and get $75 off your
order by going to burrow comm slash xx
xx I guess it's supposed to be BER I was
like I was like that's a weird one
that's bu rrow comm / xx xx nobre [ __ ]
475 doesn't like [ __ ] Ron Burgundy
god damnit he'll read anything there /
burr I should say for $75 off your
purchase burrow makes the luxury couch
for real alright let's get to some of
the questions for this week I guess
that's what we'll do a couple of
questions and then we'll can go back to
some more advertising if I can actually
figure out how to read it
alright Russia feeling left out hey you
build burov I've been listening to you
taught you talking about your upcoming
Eastern European tour in the latest
podcast but not hearing about any stops
in Russia leaves me quite scarred and
traumatized
every time the podcast ends is this guy
making fun of Millennials or how soft
Americans are or are Millennials a
worldwide problem I mean what's the deal
with leaving us out stand-up is very
popular here right now stand-up in
Russia I mean are you allowed to talk
about anything I can't see going over
there doing a Vladimir Putin [ __ ]
impression could I then what happens all
of a sudden somebody spray some mist on
me and I'm sure you can easily pack a
full show several times over in places
like Moscow and st. Petersburg besides
think of all the experiences you can
have in the og vodka capital of the
world it's dirt cheap with the current
exchange rates the cities are beautiful
and quite different from what you see
anywhere else the people are friendly
welcoming and fun-loving was this
written by the KGB or is this really a
regular person you never know I mean we
haven't gotten along
a long time I know it kind of died down
for a minute but you know it's always
gonna be Yankees and Red Sox with us
unfortunately to be honest with you dude
I'm actually I was talking to my agent
about trying to add Moscow which I
shouldn't have said because now
everybody's always trying to add it and
then if I don't that I'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ] anyway she said I know we have a
bad rap currently even heard you
mentioned that gay people and
journalists are being killed here which
would be laughable to us if not so many
people believe those stories uh oh you
don't say oh my god am I um who's living
under the right media bubble anyways but
let me ask just ask you one thing if
you're so skeptical about trusting the
media in your everyday life why go
around and believe what that same media
is spewing about other countries not
saying you should take my word for it
come and see for yourself hey come on
over bill we're not killing anybody over
here grab it
make your own decision in the meantime
give a little gift of laughter to melt
our cold my shreeka loving hearts I
don't even say it
have a nice day and go [ __ ] yourself oh
man um no I would love to [ __ ] go
over there and uh I don't know what the
[ __ ] to believe but I do know this we're
not the only ones lying you know okay so
don't believe the American media but
believe my media about my country well I
guess maybe I should believe I mean look
I don't think I would if I went over
there yeah I would be honest I don't
know maybe you're being honest who the
[ __ ] knows you know I think we should
just grow up and join forces okay AARP
oh hi Bill hmm I've heard on your
podcast that you all wait by the way
have you guys seen the Vladimir Putin
[ __ ] goes out plays hockey and they
just let him score right and left I got
a [ __ ] post that video you know
that's that type of [ __ ] you don't mean
like do you think they'd let Donald
Trump score they probably would but we
always had that thing oh they're not
letting him score because they don't
wanna get sent to Siberia AARP
hi Bill hey you know something I would
like to hear from more Russian people I
want you guys to infiltrate my [ __ ]
podcast here like you did the last
election Oh a heartache I don't know if
you did that I have no idea I don't pay
I don't watch the news AARP hi Bill I
heard on your podcast that you received
AARP invitation to join the biggest
benefit we get from AARP is that it's is
a very large lobbyists for us old people
please join thanks oh my god did I just
join a group yeah for those who didn't
listen last week I'm 50 years old now
mooch makes me qualified for AARP and I
can I can go to the movies for like
eight dollars you know I can get a
custom cane walking cane or something if
I want there's a whole bunch of things I
can do I'm actually you know what I was
on the road and I saw there was an email
it was something I needed to fill out
anyways plowing ahead further you know I
gotta be honest with you guys I'm always
honest on this podcast last night yeah
had this little square of [ __ ] weed
and she goes take a bite of it I gotta
hate eating wheat I don't like eating it
and she goes down just try as I want to
do so she talks me into it I'm eating
dinner and I ate the [ __ ] thing and I
never really felt anything and about 10
minutes ago in this podcast all of a
sudden it [ __ ] hit me like 12 hours
later you know I'm not like [ __ ]
tripping but I think that's why I was
reading like xx xx twice instead of once
I have no idea that this [ __ ] is
supposed to make you like clearer
I really miss booze I mean you just kind
of know what's gonna happen like what's
going on right now is just like some
Bruce Lee [ __ ] it's my brain swell up
now and I just keel over on my own
podcast anyways
nutrition you goofy bald-headed bat
bald-headed potato lookin [ __ ] Jesus
Christ you're harsh in the mellow man I
know you are looking to go to a
nutritionist for advice be warned this
industry isn't particularly well
regulated yeah
I know it's terrifying basically once
they they have that degree they don't
have an any oversight like real doctors
if they [ __ ] you over there's only so
much that you can do well I could sue
them but then you already saying they
don't have the money of a doctor so
what's the point here's what you should
do a find a nutritionist that provides
advice based on lab work
most of these [ __ ] will just have you
keep a food journal and then give you
advice based on what you ate over the
week this is stupid
and can be both misleading and
inaccurate not to mention expensive lab
finally attrition that provides advice
based on lab work well I mean is this
can't you just [ __ ] sit there thrown
out stats four to five doctors
recommended this is barriers anyways be
whatever product they get you to start
taking ask them if they get money for
the referral and what are they gonna say
yes a good nutritionist won't try to
sell you something just because they get
a kickback and an even better one will
give you a list of options of things you
can do based on your blood work or not
me this all makes sense I guess I hate
people that have to give their opinion
give you their credentials as a means of
validating their opinion but for context
I'm a member of Team USA and competed in
the 2006 Olympics and real Jesus Christ
if I can throw in your dick on the table
here the only reason why I say this is
that is for the example that Team USA is
sponsored by coca-cola and even our
nutritionist attempt to hook us up on
protein brand on a protein brand owned
by Coke yeah that's how it works
everybody has a side deal despite it
being an inferior and more expensive
product Wow they recommended it to the
athletes isn't that and it was and there
was gold medals on the line anyways just
saying be careful we listen to they even
do elite athletes with this [ __ ] well
you know what that's probably one of the
most informed [ __ ] emails I ever read
or yeah I guess is an email right letter
when I was a car when I was a kid they
called them letters yeah I got I know I
have
to watch out for them one of the reasons
I got a nutrition in this is because
when I went online anything that I
looked up about food I mean the whole
front I don't know how many pages was
just all big-time websites and and then
just everything was conflicting you know
these are good don't eat those I'll tell
you got belly fat you know what the
problem is bananas a lot of people think
bananas are [ __ ] it's just like you
know I don't know I love them people do
then you start telling you like certain
fruits and vegetables are bad for ya
well I imagine if I eat a [ __ ] bushel
of them it's not good but isn't it also
like some sort of potassium or some [ __ ]
I get out of bananas I don't know
gorillas eat him they look pretty
[ __ ] buff 23andme here's the old
Billy cheeto oh hey there Billy
okay cheeto dick oh man come on man link
to the article at the bottom but I know
you don't read so here's the gist all
right hang on a second 23andme is
getting lots of money from big pharmacy
what the [ __ ] is this okay anyway he
goes alright he goes you were absolutely
right this company 23andme
is set to make 300 million from sharing
their users generic information with big
pharmacy oh is that one of those like
ancestry.com websites they say it's so
the buying company can use the data to
develop medical breakthroughs or some
[ __ ]
but I'm sure we all know that's [ __ ]
except except to see Robot replacements
within a decade or two
anyways thought you could use some
vindication from a fellow conspiracy
nuts have a good one and go swap your
own spit go [ __ ] yourself umm I would
actually guess that all of that is true
okay that they're going to use all of
that information to develop new drugs I
would think because they're trying to
make money none of which will cure you
they'll just keep you you know on the
hook we'll keep him a little just alive
enough that he keeps buying a little
pill and then I also think the robots
are going to come
absolutely you know but the bottom line
is is the people who are making the
robots are overseeing it are also human
so it's in their best interest to try
and cure [ __ ] for other humans right I
already told you my philosophy right my
[ __ ] theory was basically I should
have told you guys about that [ __ ]
stupid pot square thing cuz right now
you're like oh man this is because he's
high you know [ __ ] people who are
like into weed always give it credit you
know like I didn't already have this
thought I had this paranoid thought
Stone sober alone in a hotel room this
is what I think I think that they're
gonna [ __ ] use this [ __ ] to build
robots in and they gonna kill everybody
off and keep a certain amount of people
alive and their job is gonna be to like
keep reproducing so the Illuminati can
harvest the organs god that's gotta be
from the Weed Man no I swear to God
I've actually said that on stage this
weekend Stone sober after eating a salad
you know a lot of those salads actually
have chemicals sprayed all over em so
you're actually I know I know there's no
[ __ ] way around it alright bill from
a lady hey Bill DeBlasio Blasi [ __ ] de
Blasio [ __ ] I'm a relatively recent
listener of your podcast as of seeing
you at cluster fest in San Francisco a
year ago and sentence makes no sense I
am a relatively recent listener of your
podcasts as of seeing you at cluster
fest in San Francisco a year ago alright
I guess that does make sense but it's
kind of written in a passive-aggressive
Shakespearean way you could have [ __ ]
arranged the letters a little more
straightforward there all right I'm not
gonna live that one right there that was
the weed I literally have a meeting in a
half hour like what the I'm just gonna
fight I can't imagine the show I'm going
to agree to do all right not looking
where I was going I almost accidentally
walked into you while you were on your
way to interview Jerry Seinfeld most is
the same way
I probably came off as rude from my deer
in the headlights moments of literally
running into one of the best comedians
of all time did I write this so hope you
can accept my late apology what am i
[ __ ] in Lord of the Rings here yes you
are forgiven
she is spared I thought you interview
and headliner act was terrific and hoped
to see another one of your shows that
was one of the coolest [ __ ] days ever
by the way I [ __ ] got got to do my
own I do own show that day no it was a
day after I finished my show the next
day I got to interview Jerry Seinfeld in
a theater in front of them
I don't know a couple thousand people
while he promoted the latest season of
comedians and cars had a great time and
then I walked out the door and I had a
car service to go over with Josh Adam
Meyers we had a book the car service to
go to the NBA Finals to see like Game
three of the NBA Finals
Golden State burst the Cleveland
Warriors and the driver was so cool he
let us smoke cigars in the back come on
man one of the great [ __ ] days of my
life anyways I'm glad you mentioned you
wanted more women to write into your
show now I'd love yeah because I love
trashing you okay I would like to hear
it what it is you you think I would love
if you had more female guests on your
podcast oh I don't think I've ever had a
woman on my podcast does that mean I'm
sexist I don't think I actually appeal
to women and I can tell you why because
my shows are sausagefest and when I go
outside I can't tell you how many times
somebody will be like it'll be a couple
and they want a picture and like the
wife or girlfriend takes the picture and
they never want one just the guy does so
I mean I don't know I think maybe this
is just like I don't know I'm trying to
think of something that's so strictly
for guys like footballs you know I'm
basically that version trying to pick
something to actually offend women
footballs are for everybody anyways I
was wondering if you could give me some
dating advice society generally teaches
when
at a young age that men are suitors and
women are courted but as a 27 year old
woman who dates women sometimes it gets
particularly difficult to figure out who
does what role especially if both women
are very feminine well at that point you
got to step it up also just be a staring
contest right
sometimes these roles just fit naturally
but other times there isn't a clear
sense of direction and the whole thing
just falls apart let me ask you this all
right because opposites attract they
always say and I've dated people who
were too similar to me and it's just we
want a yin and a yang we were two Yanks
so we had half the [ __ ] thing taken
care of and the rest was a [ __ ] show so
in the lesbian world all right if both
women are feminine does that have less
of a chance of making it as a
relationship we want to hear from
lesbians we're taking college it fatback
that sometimes these roles just fit
naturally is but other times there isn't
a clear sense of direction and the whole
thing just falls apart I'm also not
naturally comfortable with approaching
women advise or social events and then
eventually wait for someone else to make
the first move
Arisa why you got all the power here
because it's it's it's all women right
so there's no [ __ ] there's nothing
hope there's nothing holding you back
here
other than that voice in your head going
what if she says no recently I feel like
I've missed out on some good
opportunities for dates because of this
what advice would you give to someone
who isn't used to being the proactive or
leading role in a dating situation
thanks and best wishes to your family oh
yeah and go [ __ ] yourself well why don't
you just start hitting on somebody
you're not interested in you know just
as practice and just say the stupidest
dumbest most over-the-top [ __ ] I mean
I'm applying this to as a guy if you're
afraid to talk to women it's kind of
like you got to see the humor in it you
got to see the humor and getting up
thinking someone gave you a look like
yeah I'm into you and you walk all the
way over there and it turns out they
were looking at
somebody else or whatever you say to
them just completely bombs and then
instantly in that moment you know I
should just turn around and walk back to
where I was but just out of some stupid
pride you'll continue to stand there for
ten minutes no adding rather than
ripping the band-aid off just slowly
tearing it off so that person can reject
you for another [ __ ] sixth of an hour
oh she said PS I've been vegan for six
plus years and found it does work it
does wonders for my health changing my
diet literally cured a moderate skin
condition I had since I was a child if
you're still curious about giving
veganism and trust a tester on sorry I'd
say try it out for a month and see how
you feel it definitely works for me but
I know that's not the case for everyone
who tries it yeah I'm trying to be lazy
about learning how to do it well I just
like go to a nutritionist teach me you
know I'm just like hang out with
somebody that's you know show me someone
just give me a [ __ ] big you know what
I wish they just had like I'm giant
March Madness like poster for how to be
a vegan like that easy you know what I
mean like you look okay these two teams
play now this team's names here so I
know it won that game I wish they could
just [ __ ] do that and break it down
and the bracket leads to the finals
which is protein or at least the [ __ ]
whatever the [ __ ] whatever else you need
carbohydrates I don't [ __ ] know I
swear to God I am literally gonna sue my
girl my wife for [ __ ] drugging me
here I came to keep my [ __ ] thoughts
straight at this point girlfriend's
arguably racist family oh boy oh Jesus
I'm a black guy in Louisiana with the
girlfriend who's white her family is
very religious and reserved as am i
although we are kind of religious her
and I none of our families per se where
we have our beliefs and don't shove them
down people's throats anyways the
problem is she has she had a kid with
the black guy right before I met her
alright she has a type
her kid is not even six months he left
her high and dry and wants nothing to do
with them now seeing as we are in the
south I asked her a normal question down
here is your family okay with you dating
a black guy that question gets asked all
over the country by the way it's there's
this myth that racism is just down in
the south she was very honest and said
yeah my mom and dad should be fine
he eats fried chicken every Sunday so
you'd love him she said that my
grandparents and that generation not so
much well she was making I guess this is
a joke this is one like reading it you
like I don't know how this was said
anyways fair enough I'll work with that
the problem is after she talked me up to
her mom and and her mom saw a picture of
me she was like oh no he's black you're
just gonna get hurt so I don't know if
her mom was just inherit inherit oh and
however did the racism or if she feels
that way because the black guy ditched
her pregnant daughter how do I approach
this they live in the woods Jesus Christ
this sounds like a [ __ ] Tarantino
movie you know one of those little
shorts that he makes you know and going
back to visit them is kind of sketchy to
me and I haven't told my mom because
she'd have an aneurysm yeah don't go in
the woods of [ __ ] Louisiana to
[ __ ] visit some fish girls like get
out don't [ __ ] do that and their kids
again the chicken wait a minute
this is get out you [ __ ] is that
what this is oh I've been had you know
what that's embarrassing anyways rough
and rowdy brought no way is it did she
get pregnant in that movie now I don't
know if that's real enough hey Nia she's
probably left left the scene of the
crime all right
well I get a couple more advertisements
to read here oh the black tux everybody
Masen action the black tux
oh Jesus wedding season is upon us
now if they always get married in this
summer right after a broke-ass couple
there's no air-conditioning in the
[ __ ] church and then there they're
the ones always want to have the long
[ __ ] religious ceremony wedding
season is upon us you're going to be
doing it big and going out to all of
your buddy's weddings when you're
bringing a date you want to look fresh
but it has to be convenient that's where
the black tux comes in the black tux has
awesome suits and tuxedos and all kinds
of styles and you rent them online the
black tux offers the kind of suits and
tuxedos styles that would normally be
wildly expensive to buy and you might it
only wear it once like the Emerald shawl
tuxedo it's funky it's cool how many
times are you going to wear an emerald
green tuxedo with the black tux you can
do you can do you do you man and blow it
out for your big one-time event so try a
new look do something different and take
your style to the next level with the
black tuk-tuks free home try on you can
see the fit and feel the quality of your
suit months before your event after
ordering your suit will arrive 14 days
before your event if anything is less
than perfect the black tux will send you
a replacement right away and remember
how simple returns are where or Jesus
Christ almost funk forgot how to speak
English oh where it turn heads then send
it back three days after your event
shipping is free both ways stand out at
your event for the right reasons with
the black tux to get $20 off your
purchase visit the black tux calm slash
burn
that's the black tux calm slash burger
for $20 off your purchase the black tux
premium rental suits and tuxedos
delivered and lastly but not leastly
simply think simply safe these guys
obsess over the details that it's why
the alarm system is so good
here's an example a typical glass break
sensor
sometimes gets pulled of false positive
sounds like drop plates a baby crying I
was I supposed to like here's an example
was I supposed to only try to make a fun
example I never know what this copy
simply safe didn't want to settle for
typical because really good home
security should be really accurate
so they actually constructed a glass
break test facility also he breaks
classic okay should be a break glass
test facility glass break they ran over
ten thousand live glass breaks
situations refining their detection
technology it was so accurate it can
distinguish a broken plate from a broken
window how [ __ ] boring was that and
what is there some guy looking at like
the the the volume the thief it's the
same sound wave to get 500 different
sounds of broken glass
what if somebody breaks a window with a
wine glass honey sorry I'm not gonna be
home tonight yeah I I got a break you
know I gotta see what happens when you
frisbee a plate into some [ __ ]
stained glass but you know what god
bless these guys for doing it this is
the level of details simply safe puts
into everything they do they're the
Daniel day-lewis of breaking glass it
sets them apart from other security
companies simply safe system is designed
so you'll never notice it never have to
think about it it's that it's that easy
and intuitive there's no contract they
work hard to earn your business 24/7
monitoring with police and fire dispatch
it's just 15 dollars a month it's the
best around-the-clock protection you can
find order your simply safe security
system today it's simply safer calm and
simply safe we'll donate one to a family
in need that simply safer calm simply
safe bird calm it's an I know why and
simply alright that's gonna be the
podcast for Monday July 30th I'll check
in on you on Thursday
have a great week and go [ __ ] yourselves
you